Jayne Skinner Goodell how are you Jane
hello rich thanks for having me got it
this documentary is all kinds of awesome
thank you you are welcome so happy that
it's out there I've just been working on
it for about two years and finally
finally convinced these four to go on
camera and do it they were very
reluctant to be in the spotlight I'm so
happy people are watching it well they
were reluctant to do what this
documentary was born out of correct
which was a panel that you emceed you
hosted at the owners meeting a couple of
years ago is that correct Jane yeah it
actually all started kind of a funny
backstory which I think any football fan
would appreciate so Virginia McCaskey
house McCaskey is 96 years old right she
is but most every sport portrait or have
asked has said she no hasn't watched
more professional football than anybody
who is alive on the planet today so I
thought wouldn't that be a fantastic
documentary she's 96 and I didn't think
twice about it when I called at FL Films
to say are you guys interested and they
said did she say yes so her son George
Mackowski said she likes the email so to
email her so I put together this very
professional sounding email and how I
would be doing the interview and we know
each other and it won't be that big a
deal we'll use a lot of great archives
footage of her dad and I knew she'd be a
little shy but I had no idea I sent it
on a Saturday night September 2017
Monday afternoon I got an email back
from Virginia McCaskey saying dear Jane
I was so surprised to see your email in
my inbox on gameday so I sent it on a
Saturday night she picked it up on the
morning of the game the Bears did not
win and she sent it back and said not on
your life what I do I want to be on
television so from there we started and
I spoke to all for the multiple times
and finally Pat Rooney said uh you know
we give up we would we cry uncle let's
just do a little panel together and so
we put them together on that panel what
you see in the movie and then once that
happened Virginia came up to me
afterwards and said I get it I get that
people want to hear what we have to say
I'll do whatever you like and I said
would you like to make a movie and she
as only Virginia can do with a twinkle
in her eye said email me I did and we
were off and running last season to
shoot it so what did you learn what did
learn Jane cuz you've seen a ton of
football and you've been around or the
the power base of the league what did
you learn from from these four great
ladies well you know it's just anything
we have a peanut Charles Tillman talking
in this film about any time you have a
chance to spend time with people who are
in their 80s and 90s and who are still
so vibrant and thriving you know pull up
a chair and listen because there is so
much to learn from them commitment
dedication I think taking a long view
you know not getting sweating the small
stuff
they have incredible senses of humor but
really what I thought was so interesting
is first of all I knew there were
big-time fans and competitive but I had
no idea the depth of their passion for
this game and their intensity so we had
a lot of negotiations with the film's
crews trying to get inside their Suites
to you know to film them to film them at
home those kinds of things they did not
want anything to distract him from the
game and they come from very very
different backgrounds but and I was
really struck though about what ties
them together um not only their passion
and their intensity but just how
grateful they are how dedicated they are
to their communities they look at this
to have a football team in an American
city as an honor all of them they said
it multiple times we don't take this for
granted we are all about protecting this
legacy which I thought at the end of the
day was a really kind of beautiful
message and I think and I hope that
comes through in the film well sure does
I mean one of my favorite parts is
Martha Ford I believe is the one who
said that she's been through and she's
seen a lot but she's still missing the
the visit of a friend
and and a friend called Lombardi like
this is what she's focusing on right now
and she's been running the team for the
last six years she's 94 she's been
running the team since 88 since she was
an 88 year old correct yeah and think
about that so she'd been living that
football life since she got married to
Bill when they were 21 years old and you
know she was very quietly in the shadows
never looking for the spotlight but she
was preparing that whole time the two of
them were preparing for this happens
would 88 imagine the reaction in the
media amongst fans in Detroit saying
this 88 year old woman is not going to
be running our team now that Bill Ford
has passed away and she called a press
conference and guess what I'd like to
win a little party
trophy too and our coach is going to be
leaving us our general manager is going
to be leaving us there's a new sheriff
in town and as you said that was about
five six years ago and she's still
running that team day-to-day I mean we
have Bill Belichick in the movie talking
about this a few weeks ago in August she
was out there at training camp in the 90
degree weather talking to players
chatting with Brady it's quite amazing
yeah I mean why do you think people
would find that jarring though right
that that that a woman like Martha Ford
would be sitting here saying I want to
win a Lombardi Trophy where where as a
male owner says it's totally
understandable Jane I'm serious well no
it's funny so this came up at the very
beginning of this process is we were
talking a lot about film clips and what
what sequences to use we have such great
stuff in such great access and our
opening shot of which you'll see in the
movie for people who haven't seen it is
Martha Ford and she's you know the tiny
woman in her business suit but the big
sunglasses there for business on game
day and she's getting out of a big fleet
of SUVs of black SUVs and somebody said
I don't know if I I don't know if that's
so flattering myself hold on a second if
that was Robert Kraft getting out of
that fleet of SUVs or Jerry Jones or
whoever else you know the owners of
teams are we would have said mmm look at
them write their bosses and she's doing
as much as any of those guys are on a
daily basis and so thankfully we fought
to keep it in and we fought to just
portray it their lives as they are and
and thankfully they were very good to us
and allowing us to have all that
accident a lifetime of Sunday's you can
catch it on NFL Network Friday 3:00
Eastern Time noon pacific co-executive
producer along with Julie Hadden who I
work with and I think the world of
co-executive producer with Julie had and
Jane Skinner Goodell here on the Rich
Eisen show and you got out there too
Jane it's good to see you in like sort
of a reporting role like right I mean do
you do you miss the news business every
now and then every now and then not so
much every day I actually was back on
Fox I was that or the news reporter for
Hannity anybody who doesn't know for
about 20 years in a Cell Fox News
Channel for about 12 and so I've been
gone which I didn't realize I was on
with Shepard Smith the other day talking
about the movie and I said I had to
Google myself I didn't realize how long
I've been gone for it was eight years so
I've been in retirement mode for a while
so it's really fun to get back in and
dig into something that I'm like a labor
of love for me and the luckiest person
in the world to be able to spend a
season with these ladies and you know
someone says you can work with NFL Films
trying to explain to my friend who's a
non sports fan I said that's like
telling you you can work with Scorsese
there's no doubt by the way there's no
doubt and the grind which I've been
doing NFL the grind on epics for the
last two weeks and hopefully for a very
long time with NFL Films I'm like a
million percent do I get to work with
NFL Films and do voiceovers and have the
the film's with the spinning football
and the storytelling I am all-in and and
this is another example of it a lifetime
of Sundays it's beautifully shot there
are times when you get choked up I mean
it's it's really great it's awesome we
had a lot of big men crying who's seen
and Andy Reed is probably the
Commissioner broke down pretty hard was
not right yes and Roger tells a funny
story that he said a couple weeks after
Roger had to leave the stage we screamed
this at the NFL annual meeting this
spring the group of about six to seven
hundred people a lot of big huge guys
coaches owners players in the room and
Roger was supposed to close us out the
lights come up after the film he's
supposed to say good night and he's
crying so hard that he has to leave this
stage and he had a couple weeks later he
was in a meeting and he looked out and
Andy Reed was sitting in the audience
and Andy put his index fingers to his
eye like he was making a little tear
fall down to be making fun of him but
Andy was crying just as hard so great
well I mean you know obviously because
Norma hunt is featured and she has been
to all 53 Super Bowls which might be a
surprise to some people except for the
fact that she was married to the
gentleman who named the game the Super
Bowl so and I thought that the really
touching part which actually a reporter
in Kansas City told me that most people
in KC had not heard that story before
that her son talked about and she talked
about it in the film she's like she's a
lot on this Super Bowl streak for some
sort of ego boost of her own she's busy
with it
she was at 53 this year she's there
because as one more Hunt was dying he
said to his sons
this is what you can do for me you can
keep mom streak going it's so important
to me that she continues you know to go
to the game so she said to her it's
honoring him and his legacy which I
thought this is really such a beautiful
story
well obviously Jane we could go on and
on about all of this and the last couple
of minutes left I do have with you if
you don't mind I'm going to take for
myself here and and turn to thank you
there is a writ there's an iron-rich and
isin Jane as you know you know so I have
a fantasy football team and I'd like to
ask you on your football acumen here
rely on all of that it does involve
Patrick mahomes of normal hunts Kansas
City Chiefs four by the way a fantasy
football team named man spread Center
piece based on Andy Reid's photograph he
took at this past year's owner meeting
with him putting his left and right legs
wherever he damn well please and say
come at me right in the middle of that
photograph would you would you mind
chiming in as to whether I should make
this trade Jane if you don't mind here
I've been listening to you okay so I
know what it is okay I'm no Kay Adams
but I am willing to take a stab at it
and here's where my expertise comes in
okay I'm going to bring a dose of
reality to your fantasy world right
because I was a reporter some all about
the facts I did some research this
morning okay on your show the Rich Eisen
show on August 20th of this year you had
Michael Fabiano on your quote was you
Michael are the worst person to trade
with yes any quote yes that's correct
and you said earlier in the show quote
I'll never get my home's you said
Michael's fantasy gods they punish you
so here's what I have to say you written
do not take the bait I think you're
obsessed with repeating your wind from
last year and you're taking your eyes
off the prize
Patrick mahomes is a fantasy mm-hmm and
I should just I should just like Andy
Reid just stand my ground and just say
come at me is that what you're saying I
don't want to see it I don't want to
my I'm Roger and I have 20 nage
daughters who are you think you're a big
football fan there's just like his
proudest moment we have raised the most
intense fantasy players and I did text
them this morning they're supposed to be
in class but I said what are your
thoughts
am i off base here and the first one
they said who's inside end
it's Jason Witten Jason went and right
and then the other one said it's all
depends on who the Chiefs are playing
ooh it's mahomes versus Lamar Jackson
and they said he's a fantasy stud keep
Pat thank you James Skinner Goodell
that'll wrap it up not just for the
trade but this conversation Congrats on
this this documentary it's all its life
as I mention it's just terrific really
so much and if anybody wants to stream
it it's also and you can't catch it
tomorrow but I hope you watch the NFL
Network it's also in the ESPN app very
good James Skinner Goodell will chat
down the line thanks for coming out
thanks red you bet anytime that's the
co-executive producer of a lifetime of
Sundays just a great documentary from
NFL Films and ESPN for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app